und jetzt so etwas das man durchaus
einem historischen momenten nennen
könnte es ist die letzte rede hier im
parlament von peer steinbrück aus der
spd-fraktion was war er mich alles in
seiner politischen zeit
ministerpräsident kanzlerkandidat
finanzminister jetzt also hier sein
abschied aus dem deutschen bundestag
sehr der präsident meine lieben kollegen
kollegen
es ist hier begrüßenswertes die
auswärtige kultur und bildungspolitik
heute so prominent auf der tagesordnung
steht und dabei hoffentlich auch die ihr
gebührende öffentliche aufmerksamkeit
erfährt
ich will versuchen sie aus meinem
blickwinkel es einzuordnen
es gibt nicht wenige die mit der
gleichzeitigkeit eine reihe von
entwicklungen seit 2014/2015 von einer
zeitenwende einer zäsur in sie beziehen
sich dabei auf die auflösung mindestens
auf die tiefe erschütterung der
postsowjetischen friedensordnung mit der
erstmaligen und andauernden nach wie vor
andauernden territorialen
infragestellung eines landes im
nachkriegseuropa sie beziehen sich auf
den zusammenbruch staatliche strukturen
weit über den nahen osten hinaus mit der
folge einer flüchtlingsbewegung die in
unserem land korrespondierend beides
ausgelöst hat eine bewundernswerte
willkommenskultur und auch in der fremde
texte sie beziehen sich auf die
renationalisierung tendenzen in europa
auch in europa die im rückzug in die
eigene wagenburg schotten runter alles
dicht machen die antwort auf die
bewahrung von status und auch identität
sehen und sie beziehen sich auf den
aufstieg von autoritären regime und der
offenbar verbreiteten sehnsucht nach
autokratischen führungsfiguren ja wenn
man so will das normative projekt des
westens von dem der historiker heinrich
august winkler redet und schreibt den
wir übrigens keineswegs immer selber
entsprochen haben und entsprechend hat
sich nach der letzten zeitenwende 1990
1991 nicht so durchgesetzt wie das viele
von uns damals euphorisch nach der
auflösung
in einer ideologischen system konkurrenz
gesehen oder angenommen haben
im gegenteil er steht unter druck von
innen und von außen
es ist umgeben von einer reihe von
gesellschaftlichen und politischen
modellen die sich unseren werten den
unveräußerlichen freiheitsrechten der
demokratie der rechtsstaatlichkeit den
menschenrechten auch der trennung von
staat und kirche entziehen und wir sind
umgeben von militärisch und hybrid
geführten konflikten von
menschenrechtsverletzungen von
humanitären notlagen ja vielleicht sogar
von humanitären katastrophen in diesen
zeiten über die klassische außen und
sicherheitspolitik über die kunst aber
auch den frost der diplomatie und über
die entwicklungspolitik und humanitäre
hilfe hinaus den stellenwert der
auswärtigen kultur und bildungspolitik
herauszustreichen ist in der tat des
schweißes der edlen wert
wenn dem schweiß dann auch die
entsprechenden mittel folgen
nun handelt es sich wenn wir über die
bedeutung und die ausstattung der
auswärtigen kultur und bildungspolitik
reden und auch entscheiden
es geht darum mit hilfe von sprache von
kulturellem und wissenschaftlichem
austausch die verständigung und
zusammenarbeit zu ermöglichen und
darüber hinaus auch zivilgesellschaften
in ihrer kraft gegen den zionismus
autoritäre herrscher und regime zu
stärken indem wir jugendliche in dem wir
beruflich und akademisch auszubilden
indem wir wissenschaftler künstler
intellektuelle zu erreichen und zu
fördern sie ohne dass wir mit unserer
sprache unserer kultur unserer
wissenschaft und auch unseren zivilen
konflikt lösungsmöglichkeiten anbieten
könnten nicht aufdrängen aber anbieten
können und nicht in deutschland
besserwisserei anbieten können kann man
als unsere und das ist inzwischen ein
gängiger begriff als soft power
bezeichneten gegensatz zur militärischen
mitteln und sie kann diese auswärtige
kultur und bildungspolitik auch der
zivilen krisenprävention liegen
dabei spielt das netzwerk der mittler
organisation eine unverzichtbare rolle
und ich bin froh und dankbar dass sie in
dieser breite aufzählung viele fast die
meisten aber viele davon genannt hat
denn ihre hervorragenden arbeit nicht
nur ihre sondern auch der mittel
organisation
gehört und nachweisbar unser dank aber
in dieser reihenfolge
das wird frau roth nicht ablehnen ich
glaube aber dieser dank ist umso
aufrichtiger ihr stärker wie sie auch in
dieser arbeit unterstützen auf die
vielzahl gelungene projekte der
auswärtigen kultur und bildungspolitik
und auch den erwartungen an weitere
projekte siehe die thomas mann villa
oder auch die villa an der first avenue
in new york will ich nun aus zeitgründen
nicht eingehen das steht alles und
lesenswert in dem gemeinsamen antrag von
cdu csu spd und bündnis 90 die grünen
deshalb seid mir erlaubt die restliche
zeit mich oder zu nutzen mich von ihnen
als ein aktiver politiker und
parlamentarier zu verabschieden
das leben uns zu einem längeren
hoffentlich nicht langatmig im resümee
ein dass der präsident aber in genau
vier minuten und 57 sekunden
unterbrechen würde deshalb nur so viel
ich deutete mit der wahrnehmung einer
zeitenwende oder eine zäsur an dass wir
in fragilen zeiten leben auch in europa
gemessen allerdings am zustand europas
von nur zwei generationen relativiert
man möge zurückdenken ich gehöre nach
der generation meines urgroßvaters und
meines großvaters an meines vaters als
jemand der 1947 geboren ist zu der
ersten generation die nicht auf den
schlachtfeldern europas geopfert worden
ist dieses europäische einigungswerk
dass mir und meiner generation die es
ermöglicht hat ist ein glücksfall der
jeden einsatz dafür rechtfertigt dass es
so bleibt
das bedeutet aber liebe kollegen
kollegen dass wir dafür sorgen müssen
dass dieser wunderbare kontinent nicht
auf den euro nicht auf die ezb
zinspolitik nicht auf nächtliche sitzung
des europäischen rates nicht einmal auf
dem brett und schon gar nicht auf den
krümmungsgrad der salatgurke reduziert
dieses europa nicht nur die antwort auf
die katastrophen der ersten hälfte des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts sondern auch
auf die herausforderungen des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts vor dem
hintergrund einer ungeheuren dynamik im
muster globaler ökonomischer politischer
und militärischer kräfte von denen ich
manchmal den eindruck habe der sich
unsere wahrnehmung und aufmerksamkeit
entziehen in ihren rückwirkungen auf
unsere gesellschaft und auf unsere lage
in europa deutschland übrigens das land
mit den meisten europäischen direkt
gelagerten nachbarn meiner erzählung 9
direkte nachbarn hat in dieser
zentraleuropäischen geographie für den
europäischen zusammenhalt ja ich
verstehe mich zu der bemerkung für die
selbstbehauptung europas einen
besonderen beitrag zu leisten und auch
einen preis dafür zu bezahlen
im ureigensten interesse
dies liebe kollegen pflegen muss den
bürger mit verstand aber offenbar mit
noch sehr viel mehr herz erklärt werden
müssen
gegen alle angebote des rückzuges in die
eigene wagenburg aus populistischen oder
sogar chauvinistischen lagern angesichts
der spürbaren desorientierung und
verunsicherung in nicht zu
vernachlässigen teilen unserer
gesellschaft müssen wir in unseren
partei und in diesem parlament nicht nur
bezogen auf europa der ort sein
die bühne liefern auf der die zentralen
zukunftsfragen debattiert werden und
zwar kontrovers spannend laut
leidenschaftlich repolitisieren nicht
alternativ
die debatten müsse so geführt werden
weil weil damit die neugier an politik
wieder wächst weil es darüber
kommunikation geht weiß engagement
provoziert auch über ganz gegensätzliche
positionen die ausgetragen werden
tun wir das nicht übernehmen diese
debatte sehr dumpfbacken kräfte in
unserer gesellschaft an diesen
zukunftsthemen besteht in meinen augen
kein mangel
über eine notwendige gelegentlich auch
tagespolitisch orientiert der
tagesordnung hinaus einige dieser
zukunftsthemen in meinen augen sind was
ist mit freiheit und individuelle
selbstbestimmung in zeiten der
globalisierung und digitalisierung wie
steht es um die rückgewinnung des
primats demokratisch legitimierte
institutionen gegenüber einem
entgrenzten digitalen und
finanzkapitalismus was ist mit der
zukunft europas
ich deute das an oder der
generationenvertrag vor dem hintergrund
der demographie es sagt sich leicht das
rentenniveau muss gesteigert werden aber
ich müsste der generation meiner kinder
und jetzt meine vier enkelkinder
erzählen wer das denn eines tages wie
mit steuern oder arbeitslos oder
versicherungsbeiträge bezahlen soll
oder ein anderes thema ist der
zusammenhalt unserer gesellschaft vor
dem hintergrund unabweisbare interner
spaltungstendenzen aber auch das
jahrzehnt der jahrzehnte aufgabe
zuwanderern und flüchtlingen flüchtlinge
zu integrieren wo für wahrscheinlich
bildung jobs und vor allen dingen auch
wohnung der schlüssel sind und ein
anderes thema vielleicht etwas unter
beleuchtet ist in meinen augen zunimmt
die frage nach dem zusammenleben der
großen weltreligionen
ich wünsche ihnen und mir dass die
politischen parteien diesseits der
auspflanzung an den politischen rändern
in ihrer unterschiedlichkeit und in
ihrer unterscheidbarkeit und dieses haus
der ort sind wo diese
auseinandersetzungen in zukunft stärker
stattfinden wir dürfen von den bürgern
gemeinsam nicht als ein politik kartell
missverstanden werden dass ihre
befindlichkeiten weg filtert und dieses
risiko besteht
ich möchte gerne abschließen mit zwei
eher banalen erkenntnissen als ich vor
47 jahren in die spd eintrat
da dachte ich dass die verteilung von
sagen wir mal von sümpfen und
schlauberger ziemlich einseitig auf die
verteilung auf die parteien verteilt ist
und ich gehöre ich zur partei der stau
wärme
inzwischen weiß nicht wie ich zugebe
nach einer längeren lernkurve
erschaudern
dass die verteilung solche zum führer
und schlauberger in und zwischen den
parteien der normalverteilung der
bevölkerung folgt
und diese erkenntnis hat mir die
fraktion zum partei übergreifende
zusammenarbeit erleichtert wofür ich
mich sehr herzlich bedanken möchte die
zweite erkenntnis ist vielleicht gar
nicht so banal
ich lernte sie ihr steht dass es in der
politik nicht nur darauf ankommt was man
sagt und was man macht sondern auch wie
man dabei guckt und dies habe ich in
einer laudatio vor wenigen wochen auch
den kollegen schäuble noch mal gesagt
dieser präsident meinen sieben damen und
herren das war der letzte ton aus meinem
jagdhorn vielen dank
lieber kollege steinbrück sie gehören
dem deutschen bundestag aus dem sich
durch eigenen entschluss zum ende dieses
monats ausscheiden
seit 2009 an viel weniger lang als die
allermeisten innerhalb und außerhalb des
parlaments vermuten werden aber als
staatssekretär als landesminister als
ministerpräsident und als
bundesfinanzminister waren sie mehr als
25 jahre
sowohl im bundestag wie im bundesrat
präsent und haben das politische leben
in deutschland über ein gutes
vierteljahrhundert maßgeblich
mitbestimmt die art und weise ihrer
arbeit und ihrer reden und ihrer
schriften über ihre arbeit haben breite
beachtung gefunden
wenn auch nicht immer nur ihre
zustimmung
das hat sie erkennbar weder überrascht
noch wirklich erschüttert sie haben sich
den widerspruch gelegentlich vielleicht
auch das misstrauen ihrer eigenen
parteifreunde ebenso hart erarbeitet wie
den respekt ihrer politischen gegner und
ihre scheinbar ironische bemerkung
vorhin in ihren schluss bemerkungen hat
die repräsentativität dieses parlaments
für das deutsche volk noch einmal in
unnachahmlicher weise unterstrich
als bundesminister als
bundesfinanzminister haben sie auf dem
höhepunkt der weltfinanzkrise an
entscheidender stelle zusammen mit der
bundeskanzlerin einen wesentlichen
beitrag zur bewältigung der krise und
zur beruhigung der öffentlichkeit
beigetragen
wir verabschieden sie heute mit dank und
respekt aus dem bundestag in ihr drittes
leben nach der politik
und falls sie weiterhin reden halten und
oder bücher schreiben
reden sie gut über uns
wir haben es verdient sie aber auch
alles alles gute
nur beste luft